l'agroécologie c'est pas de la
cueillette c'est de l'écologie orienté
diriger vers la paire une production
agricole durable est relativement par
moments importantes parce qu'il faut
répondre à des besoins alimentaires du
troupeau je pense ça doit être dieu
c'est pas un c'est dur mentalement pour
un éleveur se dire je dois m'adapter à
ce milieu et je fais pas comme j'en ai
envie quoi ou fruits il faut prendre sur
soi et puisse dire
on fait avec ce qu'on a pas essayer de
toujours toujours chercher plus bas on
n'est pas à l'abri d'une sécheresse
n'est pas à l'abri en temps pluvieux on
sait pas ce que donne l'année
et en plus de ça il faut il faut des
connaissances techniques et c'est très
compliqué ça ivresse un vrai réel défi
voit bien que les systèmes d'aujourd'hui
ben je pense que c'est pas l'avenir
parce que parce que soit sa marche plus
ou bien via sont en train de de montrer
par exemple au niveau environnemental
que ça pourra pas marcher pour l'avenir